and I know a lot of guys and a lot of
people want to hear about losing Trayvon
uh when I first heard about it
um and seen them go down uh my heart
broke bro uh you talking about someone
who's like took me under the wing
um man and just like I man I just went
off to the side to take a moment from
practice and I just like I really shed
tears like you know
trayvon's like really like my family
like he's showing like I know we're
gonna look after each other take care of
each other
um and I don't think people realize how
much stuff that we actually do together
so and the energy that he brings to the
team so losing him may could have been a
part just because the enjoyment and the
fun that he brings to the guys that type
of energy is rare and we're truly gonna
miss him
um like for example we make sure we
bring each other food to the plane we
make sure you know we always walk out
the tunnel together we always hang out
the night before the game text talk face
time go over stuff just like it's just
truly go it's truly a bummer losing
someone like that and someone is close
and uh at this point you know he even we
saw each other right after the game you
know he called me said uh come see me
and uh you know and we just talked a
little bit more it's like man y'all
gotta y'all gotta hit it on so you know
this week is all gonna be motivation for
my dog Trey um we're gonna miss you
brother and we're gonna see you soon
um but the whole team felt your absence
and we felt that
um and I that's why I thought it was
cool that uh Stefan made you know the
big uh you know he dedicated that game
towards his brother and uh I think we're
gonna do something like that as our team
and our defense
um the dedicated game towards trade two
um because that's our brother and uh
it's not the same without him out there
so we miss you brother and we love you
and uh we know what you're gonna bring
next year uh to help us do it all over
again brother
um and even coach McCarthy said it was a
central punch uh to the gut you know
losing a guy like that like
um people who question straight
character and who he is don't really
know him
um what he brings to the team is just
undeniably uh gifted and I mean just the
turnovers he brings the excitement The
Joy like you just can't coach it and uh
you know coach Al Harris you know he
shed some tears too you know uh so I
think I think you guys are getting the
grass so what it means and what it means
to have him on this team
um and then you know we might as well
keep going getting straight to it I want
to take some questions from the chat uh
you know I know you guys have some
questions about what happened Sunday so
you know I want to hear from you guys
is it going to take time to adapt
without seven
um I think last week was our uh adaption
game you know I think we all seen what
it's like not to have him out there
um I think we all notice uh what's going
on and what we need to do and how we
need to adjust so I think this week will
be much better uh and all around the
board
uh what do I think of what BART Scott
said
um honestly it hurt me and I I just
think it's too early
um without a doubt it is a big blow to
Dallas defense to lose Trayvon Diggs
like I said the the type of guy he he is
and what he brings to our team is just
you just we can't recreate that uh and
you can't bring no one in to replace him
um so when you and as a former player I
just don't believe that you should put
that type of luck or say the type of
things you do after someone makes a
significant injury especially like ACL
it's not like Trayvon was out for four
to six weeks or he had to be in place of
ir because of hamstring
um you know uh ACL is a sees an ending
injury you know so I just don't agree
with that
um but every man is different you know
if you're going to change for the
cameras and things like that uh then
that's just who you are but as a player
and you know for where I'm going and you
know obviously doing this I would never
intentionally talk bad or uh what's your
injury and say think that's like a joke
on anyone uh I never had a significant
injury like that but um talking to guys
and seeing people go through it uh it's
just not something to joke about